[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
اداره الكوارث التركيه تسجل اكثر من 3000
وثمانيه هزه ارتداديه منذ زلزال السادس من
فبراير
الفريق السعودي التطوعي يواصل نصب مئه
خيمه يوميا لمتضرري الزلزال في كهرمان
مرعش
معدل التضخم يسجل ارتفاعا في السعوديه
خلال يناير الماضي والسكن والمواد
الغذائيه ضمن الاعلى ارتفاعا
ومن مواضيعنا في الرابعه كذلك
هيئه النقل السعوديه توقع عقدا لنقل
الركاب بالحافلات بين المدن من خلال شبكه
تصل لمئتين مدينه
وقرابه خمسه ملايين معتمر قدموا وغادروا
عبر المنافذ السعوديه منذ بدء موسم العمره
الحالي
حياكم الله البدايه من تداعيات الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا في السادس
من نوفمبر وخلف اكثر من اربعين الف قتيل
والاف الجرحى بالاضافه الى مئات المفقودين
اضافه الى الهزات الارتداديه التي اعلنت
تركيا عن تجاوزها الثلاثه الاف وثمانم
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الداخليه التركيه سليمان صويلح
عن مضاعفه عدد القوات الامنيه في المناطق
المنكوبه ثلاث مرات مشيرا الى ان هناك
احياء لا يزالون تحت الانقاض ويجري
اخراجهم باسرع وقت سويل اعلن ايضا عن هدم
50% من المباني المتضرره خلال ايام قليله
بسبب عدم صلاحيتها
هذا وتتواصل عمليات انقاذ المتضررين من
الزلزال المدمر واظهر مقطع فيديو تم
تداوله عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي عمليه
انقاذ امراه عمرها او بعمر 42 عاما في
قهرمان مرعش التركيه بعد
222 ساعه من الزلزال
ادوات واصل الفرق التطوعيه التابعه لمركز
الملك سلمان لغاز تقديم المساعدات
للمتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا حيث تعمل
بجانب ثلاثه الاف خيمه تم توزيعها خلال
الفتره الماضيه وتعمل الفرقه التطوعيه
للمركز على نصب مئه خيمه يوميا في كهرمان
مرعش
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض بالامس كنت في كهرمان مرعش
اليوم تنتقل الى موقع اخر
وانت في غازي عنتاب كيف تبدو الصوره اولا
جهود الانقاذ ايضا والبحث التقصي عن ناجح
حتى هذه اللحظه هل لا زالت مستمره
نعم نائب بالفعل انتقلنا من اماكن عديده
وعدنا من غازي عنتاب الى قهرما مرعي خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه وعدنا مجددا كنا
قبل قليل فعلا في غازي عنتاب عدنا الان
الى كهرمان منعش لي رصد عمليات الانقاذ
التي توقفت في غازيها عنتاب بشكل كبير في
مناطق مختلفه وتبقى مناطق قليله جدا هنا
في قهرمان مرعش في عدد متفرق من انحاء
المدينه تستمر اعمال الانقاذ بالاضافه الى
اعمال مساعده النازحين الذين يتواجدون في
الملاعب وفي الاماكن العامه بالاضافه الى
القرى التي المحيطه بقهرمان مرعش والتي
تواجد فيها مركز الملك سلمان اليوم وهنا
في احد الاماكن الرئيسيه في قهرمان مرعش
لا تزال عمليات الانقاذ مستمره في اليوم
العاشر من هذه الازمه التي ضرب التي وقعت
بعد ضرب الزلزال من هنا
المنطلق الزلزال ومقره الرئيسي وحيث وصلت
ارتداداته الى سوريا من قهرمان مرعش والتي
اليوم يعني كان هناك اخبار جيده من قهرمان
مرعش تم انقاذ ثلاثه سيدات سيدات سيدتين
في السبعينيات من عمرهما وسيده في
الاربعينيات الا انه تواجدنا في هذا
الموقع قبل ما يقرب الساعه وشاهدنا انتشال
عدد من الجثث في هذه
الموقعين واستمرار عمليات الانقاذ لا تزال
مستمره الامل لازال موجود لدى هذه السلطات
التي تعمل في
في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى اثار الدمار
التي بدات تبان بشكل كبير جدا الطرقات
مغلقه بجانب عمليات الانقاذ كما تشاهد في
هذا الطريق المؤدي الى مدخل هذا الحي هو
مغلق بشكل تام تستخدمه الاليات الصعبه في
عمليات الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه وعمليات
الانقاذ لن تتوقف بحسب تصريحات المسؤولين
الاتراك الذين قالوا ما دام ان هنالك فرصه
لبقاء اي شخص حيث العمليات ستستمر
بالاضافه الى ذلك تم تمشيط عدد كبير من
المنازل اي العائله للسقوط التي نشاهدها
في الصوره مثل هذا المنزل الذي يقع بقرب
هذا المكان المدمر وهو منزل خرج اهله
ويعني اربعين بالمئه من المنازل تم فحصها
الكثير من المنازل لا يستطيع اهاليها
العوده في التالي كان هنالك عدد كبير من
النازحين نتحدث عن ما يقرب 40 مليونين
نازح في مختلف الولايات التركيه العاشر
التي ضربها الازلزال بالاضافه الى ذلك لا
تزال عمليات عدم وجود خيم لبعض النازحين
لا تزال مستمره
الخيم المنتشره لا تزال يعني لا تؤدي
او لا تستوعب هذا الكم الهائل جدا من
الاشخاص الذين خرجوا من منازلهم وتبقيت
اغراضهم في هذا الموقع الذي نشاهده
وحاجياته من داخل المنزل الذي تم
استخراجها من قبل فرق الانقاذ التي تعمل
باستمرار في مناطق مختلفه حيث في هذا
الموقع وفي مواقع مختلفه من المدينه لا
تزال تعمل فرق الانقاذ بالاضافه الى ذلك
تم رصد عدد من الهزات التي
وقعت هنا في قهرمان مرعش بالاضافه الى
غازي عنتاب يوم امس عند الساعه الثالثه
صباحا كان هنالك هزه ارضيه شعرنا بها في
غازي عنتاب وصلت تاثيراتها الى هنا وقبل
ساعه من الان في هذا الموقع تحديدا كان
هنالك هزه ارضيه الخوف من الهزات
الارتداديه لا تزال مستمره على هذه
المباني التي تشكل خطر جدا على القائمين
او العاملين في عمليات الانقاذ قد يكون
هنالك انهيار لهذه المباني حتى مع قيام
فرق الانتقاد بالتالي هنالك خطوره كبيره
جدا على فرق الانقاذ العامله في هذه
المنطقه وفي المناطق الاخرى جراء الهزات
الارتداديه اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل من غازي عنتاب منفذ
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي شكرا لك
وبعد مضي اكثر من اسبوعا على الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا والتركيه ما تزال
فرق الانقاذ تنجح في الوصول الى احياء تحت
الانقاض حيث شهدت الساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضيه نجاه عده اشخاص من تحت الركام
بعد 222 ساعه في ولايه قهرمان مرعش فرق
الانقاذ تنتشر التركيه مليكه على قيد
الحياه
ايضا كتبت لهما الحياه بعد تسعه ايام
منزلهما بها طاي كينسوار
كذلك استطاعت هذه الطفله النجاه في قهرمان
مرعش بعد صمود اسبوع تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
212 ساعه محاصره قبل ان تخرج حيه ترزق من
تحت الحطام
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه ايمن الصفدي
عقب لقائه بالرئيس السوري بشار الاسد في
دمشق عزم بلاده على تقديم كل المساعدات
الممكنه الى سوريا والوقوف معها لتجاوز
تداعيات الزلزال التقيت سيره الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد ونقلته تعازيز جلاله
الملك
الى جمهوريه العربيه السوريه بضحايا
الزلزال وحرص جلاله الملك وتاكيدها على ان
الاردن سيقدم كل ما يستطيعه لمساعده الشعب
السوري الشقيق على التعامل مع تبعات هذا
الزلزال الاليم الذي ذهب ضحيته الكثيرون
ووصف وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه من الصفدي
زيارته الى دمشق بانها محطه للبناء عليها
من اجل التوصل الى حل للازمه السوريه يحفظ
وحده البلد وكذلك العمل على العوده
الطوعيه للاجئين الزياره ايضا كانت محطه
لبحث علاقاتنا الثنائيه وبعض الجهود
المبذوله للتوصل لحل سياسي
للازمه ينهي هذه الكارثه حل يحفظ وحده
سوريا والتماسكها وسيادتها يعيد لها امنها
واستقرارها ودورها يهيئ الظروف التي تسمح
بالعوده الطوعيه للاجئين ويخلص سوريا من
الارهاب الذي يشكل خطرا علينا جميعا
وبالعوده الى المساعدات السعوديه لمنكوبي
زلزال تركيا وسوريا ينضم الينا من الرياض
رئيس هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي الدكتور
جلال العويسي دكتور جلال مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اولا نريد ان نعرف
اكثر عن عمل الهيئه في الجسر الجوي الجسر
الجوي طبعا بين الرياض
ومطار حلب طبعا وكذلك ايضا حتى المناطق
المتضرره والمنكوبه في جنوب تركيا كيف هو
تنسيق العمل بينكم وبين مركز الملك سلمان
للغاثه والعمال الانسانيه
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
حقيقه منذ وقوع يعني هذه الكارثه
الماساويه على الشعب التركي والشعب السوري
صدرت توجيهات مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
بتشكيل لجنه من عده جهات معنيه برئاسه
مركز الملك سلمان
وكان الهدف منها تشكيل فريق تقييم سريع
للموقف وتحديد الاحتياجات
ويمكن الان التعامل قائم ولعلم يميز
المشاركه السعوديه في هذه الاعمال انها
شملت جميع المراحل التي يمر بها المتضررين
كلنا شاهدنا على قنوات التلفزيون وجود
مصابين تحت الالقاب يحتاج الى فريق متخصص
بعمليات البحث والانقاذ تم استخراجهم
وبعضهم يحتاج الى تقديم رعايه طبيه وبعد
تقديم الرعايه الطبيه يحتاج الى ماوى
وغذاء وهنا كانت تكامل بين منظومه الدفاع
المدني بفريق البحث والانقاذ
وهيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي بتقديم
المعونه الطبيه
ومركز الملك سلمان بتقديم الاغاثه
والاعانه والهواء اريد ان اسال عن نوعيه
النوعيه الافراد الذين اوفتموهم الى هناك
اريد ان اسال اولا عن الاعداد الاعداد
الفرق التي بعثتموها وابرز ايضا حتى
ايضا التي قدمتموها الى جانب مركز الملك
سلمان للاعمال والاغاثه
العمليات الاغ
افيه من مواجهه المشغول من ناحيه اعداد
المصابين ومن ناحيه نوعيه الاصابه
والمطلوب في التعامل معه حقيقه ان نكون
جاهزين قدر الامكان في الفريق الاول الذي
تم ارساله تم ارسال عدد اربع استشاريين ما
بين تخصصات طب الطوارئ وطب الاسره
والكوارث والازمات بالاضافه الى عدد 12
فني واخصائي خدمات اسعافيه حرصنا على وجود
الجنسين من اخواتنا واخواننا الفرقه
الاسعافيه ولعلي يعني كان عندنا فرصه ان
يكون احد الفرقه الاسعافيه او الفنيين في
الخدمه الاسعافيه يتحدث اللغه التركيه
يساعد على معنى كثيرا في عمليه التواصل
ومعرفه الاعراض والتعامل معها
الان يعني يحدث التواصل مباشر دائما مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري والهلال الاحمر
التركي لتقييم الاحتياج ويمكن يعني في
مكالمه اخيره تمت مع اخي الاستاذ المهندس
خالد حبوباتي رئيس الهلال الاحمر السوري
يعني اتضح بعد فتره الان من التعامل مع
الاصابات عن بعض الاطفال فقدوا امهاتهم
وفي ظل الظروف الحاليه اصبح هناك احتياج
كبير لحليب الاطفال ويمكن كان هناك تواصل
مباشر معي في طلب هذا الدعم وتم رفع
الموقف مباشره لمركز الملك سلمان عن طريق
اللجنه القائمه والحمد لله تم تزويدهم 17
عبوه والطائره غدا لديها كميه مماثله ان
شاء الله تعالى يعني نحن نتحدث عن
اثنتان وثلاثون الف عبوه سترسل الحليب
الاطفال سترسل الى الى شمال السوري اليوم
صباحا والدفعه الثانيه ان شاء الله اريد
ان اسال كذلك عن التنسيق كذلك مع المنظمات
الدوليه الموجوده على الارض ايضا هناك ومع
ذلك ايضا الصليب الاحمر هل تواصلتم معهم
هل تواصلتم ايضا مع احد ممثليهم الموجودين
على الارض وحصروا لكم ربما الاحتياجات
الاهم في هذه المرحله
هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي هي ممثله مع
جميع الجمعيات الوطنيه في 192 دوله في
الاتحاد الدولي للصليب الاحمر
وجميعهم يجتمعوا من اجل القياديه من اجل
الانسانيه
وتم يعني فعلا التواصل مباشره باطلاق
نداءات لمتضررين سوريا عن طريق الهلال
الاحمر السوري
والهلال الاحمر التركي وصندوق الطوارئ
الخاص بالاتحاد الدولي وتم دعم هذه
النداءات عن طريق هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السوري السعودي بمبالغ للمرحله الاولى
وهناك مبادئ اخرى فعلا
دعم الجمعيات الوطنيه في تركيا وسوريا
لتحقيق اهدافها وتحقيق استجابه كامله
بالاضافه الى صندوق الطوارئ الخاص بالات
من الرياض الرئيس سيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي الدكتور جلال العويسي شكرا دكتور
جلال
شاهد معبر باب الهوى تجمعا لعائلات سوريه
اللاجئه في تركيا شردها واظهرت الصور تكدس
العائلات السوريه عند المعبر للعوده الى
سوريا
[موسيقى]
خلف زلزال تركيا وسوريا الكثير من القصص
الماساويه لاشخاص فقدوا اقاربهم وذويهم من
بينهم سيده مسنه في ريف ادلب توفي لها
خمسه من احفادها كما تعرض ابنيها
لاصابات بليغه
ويجوا لعندي
راهم كل امراه اولاده
كلمات قليله قد لا تختزل حجم معاناه هذه
السيده التي وجدت نفسها بين ليله وضحاها
وحيده بعدما خسرت من كانوا يسندون ظهرها
ويعينونها على عاديات الزمان
لحظه لم تتجاوز الدقيقه كانت كافيه لتجعل
هذه السيده تعيش ماساه حقيقيه اصابه
ابنيها ووفاه احفادها حتى منزلها لم يتبقى
منه سوى الانقاض التي جلست تبكي عليها
حسره وحزنا على قساوه
المالدي مستاجرين
ما شفت مقاعد دوني قالوا لي البنايه يا
ولادك
[ضحك]
تزالوا ذهب بخمسه من احفادها وادى الى
اصابات بليغه بابها
واحد مكسور ظهره ووعد مقصوره رقبته
[موسيقى]
دار ولادي
السيده ترفض مغادره المكان فاين لها ان
تذهب ومن عاشت لاجلهم لسنوات التهمهم
الزلزال والدمار
بدي اتفرج ادوري
عشان اشوف دوري قبل ما يشيلوه كل امنيتها
الان ايجاد جفاميل المفقودين تحت الانقاض
والقاء نظره وداع اخيرا لن تواسيها حجم
الماساه وسام ذهبي العربيه
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
نحو خمسه ملايين معتبر قدموا وغادروا عبر
المنافذ السعوديه منذ بدء موسم العمره
الحالي
حياكم الله من جديد قبل استئناف الرابع
نتابع هذا الفيديو من تركيا لانقاذ السيد
وطفليها من تحت انقاض مبنى في انطاكيا
التركيه بعد
228 ساعه من الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا اذا انفرق الانقاذ تنجح في
عمليه
لاجلاء سيده وطفليها من تحت انقاذ مبنى في
انطاكيا التركيه بعد 200 بعد
228 ساعه من الزلزال وتنقلهم كما نشاهد
الان في سياره
الاسعاف اذن هذه صور ننقلها لكم من
انطاكيا التركيه
لعمليه انقاذ المسعفين لسيده وطفليها من
تحت انقاذ مبنى دمر بشكل كامل انطاكيا
التركيه بعد قرابه 230 ساعه من الزلزال
[موسيقى]
سجل مؤشر معدل التضخم في السعوديه ارتفاعا
بنسبه
3.4% في يناير 2023 ذلك مقارنه بالشهر
المماثل من 2022 هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه
اشاره الى ان اسعار السكن والمواد
الغذائيه كانت هي الدافع الاكبر لارتفاع
المؤشر المزيد من الارقام مع الزميل
العنود العبدلي
وصل معدل التضخم السنوي في السعوديه
ارتفاعه لشهر الثاني على التوالي ليصل الى
ثلاثه واربعه اعشار في المئه هذا ما اظهرت
هيئه الاحصاء في بيانها اليوم مشيره الى
ان ارتفاع الحالي في معدل تضخم جاء متاثرا
بسته عوامل اساسيه فكما نشاهد هنا
مشاهدينا ارتفعت الايجارات الفعليه
للمساكن بنسبه سبعه وسبعه اشهر في المئه
في يناير عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين هذا ارتفاع
مشاهدينا انعكس على زياده اسعار ايجارات
الشقق بنسبه 19 وثلاثه اعشار في المئه
الذي يشكل الوزن الاضخم في المؤشر ياتي
بعد ذلك ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه
بنسبه
34% اما قسم النقل مشاهدينا فسجل ارتفاعا
بنسبه 83
وسجل قسم المطاعم والفنادق والاخر ارتفاعا
بنسبه 56 اعشار
اما قسم الترفيه مشاهدينا والثقافه فقد
شهد شهد ارتفاعا طفيفا بنسبه
21% واخيرا سجل قسم التعليم ارتفاعا بنسبه
23% وعلى اساس شهري مشاهدينا فقد سجل معدل
التضخم في يناير ارتفاعا طفيفا بنسبه
عشرين في المئه مقارنه بشهر ديسمبر 2022
بحسب بيان الهيئه فكما نشاهدينا مشاهدينا
ارتفعت اسعار الايجار بنسبه واحد في المئه
اما اسعار القسم الاغذيه والمشروبات فقط
ارتفعت بنسبه خمسه اعشار في المئه وقسم
المطاعم والفنادق ارتفع بنسبه ثلاثه اعشار
في المئه اما قسم السلع والخدمات الشخصيه
مشاهدينا فقد ارتفع هو الاخر بنسبه عشر في
المئه التقرير كشف عن ارتفاع في غالب قطاع
الاغذيه والمشروبات فيما تفاوتت اسعار على
الانشائيه وقبل استعراض مشاهدينا اكثر
السلع غذائيه ارتفاعا نتابع معكم هذا
الاستطلاع من منافذ بيعها في السعوديه
والله انا ما اتوقع انها لها حدود ولكن
انها فرق واضح جدا وكبير
خصوصا بالاعوام الاخيره المواد الغ
ذائي 10%
عن السنه اللي فاتت والله ارتفاع الحقيقه
كل سنه يزيد ما ادري ايش اقول لك اقول لك
يعني لو حسبت من سنتين او ثلاث سنوات يعني
ارتفاع ما يقارب 70%
ومن اراء الناس الى تقرير هيئه الاحصاء
الذي كشف عن ارتفاع بعض السلع الغذائيه
حيث جاء اكثرها ارتفاعا الدجاج المجمد
المحلي الذي ارتفع باكثر من 35 في المئه
فيما سجل البيض المحلي ارتفاعا بنحو ثلاثه
وحسب تقرير الهيئه سجل ارتفاعا سنويا
باكثر من 12 في المئه واذا لاحظنا
مشاهدينا معدلات التضخم على اساس سنوي
خلال العام الماضي 2022 نجد ان اعلى نسبه
للتضخم سجلت بنهايه العام عند ثلاثه
وثلاثه عشر في المئه مرتفعه من
21% في يناير فيما سجلت بقيه الاشهر كما
نشاهد هنا تارجحا ضمن خط صاعد نعم وزر
الماليه السعودي كان قد اشار الشهر الماضي
في منتدى دافوس الاقتصادي الى ان التضخم
عام 20
سيتراجع في السعوديه بفضل الخطوات
الاستباقيه كما اضاف الجدعان بانه تم رصده
علامات على التضخم في شهر يوليو 2021 وتم
اتخاذ العديد من اجراءات لحمايه الاقتصاد
السعودي من تبعات هذا التضخم
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو استاذ الماليه
والاستثمار بكليه الاقتصاد بجامعه الامام
دكتور محمد ميكاني دكتور محمد حياك الله
الرابعه وش اللي دفع التضخم للزياده للشهر
الثالث على التوالي في السعوديه الى الان
وصلت الى 3.4%
طبعا كان هيئه الاحصاء يمكن اظهرت بشكل
واضح انه كان السبب الرئيسي خلف هذا
الارتفاع الى 3.4% مقارنه بنفس الفتره من
السنه الماضيه اللي هي فئه السكن
والكهرباء والغاز كان الارتفاع فيها
بحوالي 6.6% ارتفاع كبير واحنا نعرف انه
هذا وهذا الفئه بالتحديد السكن والكهرباء
والغاز تمثل 25.5% يعني من حجم المؤشر
العام بشكل كامل من مئه بالمئه تليها اللي
هي الاغذيه والمشروبات كان الارتفاع فيها
حوالي 4.2% انا اعتقد انه ارتفاع السكن
والغاز والكهرباء بحكم انه احنا عندنا
خلينا نقول يعني نمو في الاقتصاد بصراحه
وكنا ما هو مفاجئ بالنسبه لنا لاحظنا انه
في حتى يعني مؤشر مدير المشتريات بشهر
ديسمبر يعني كان حوالي
56.8% قبل كده احنا وصلنا الى حوالي يعني
58% طبعا هذا
50% فوق 50% احنا في مرحله نمو في انتعاش
عندنا في الاختصار في الانشطه غير النفطيه
وما في شك واحنا عندنا اليوم مدام انه
عندنا ولا بده يكون في عندنا نسبه تضخم
وهذا ما في شك ايضا يعني
يستدعي اقبال الكثير من الاشخاص على مساله
السكن والارتفاع الخدمات الكهرباء والغاز
في احد يقول لي دكتور انه عندنا مشاريع
اسكان كثيره وجالسه يعني يوميا يعلن عن
الاف الوحدات السكنيه في المدن الرئيسيه
بالتالي الارتفاع اليوم بهكذا شكل بهكذا
طريقه وبهذا كذا ارقام على علامات استفهام
هو لانه بالتحديد في فئه الايجارات يعني
لو لاحظت فئه الايجارات ارتفعت بحوالي 19%
واحنا عارفين اليوم في اقبال كبير حتى من
يعني غير السعوديين على المدن الرئيسيه
الرياض جدا لمكه وهي كانت الثلاث مدن
رئيسيه اللي كان فيها ارتفاع اكبر في
مساله الايجارات 16% نعتقد يعني ما ننسى
انه في مدينه جده بالتحديد اليوم عندنا
مساله القضاء العشوائيات وبالتالي دفعت
كثير من الاشخاص يخرجوا من الاحيان اللي
عشوائيه وبالتالي في اقبال اكبر على مساله
الايجارات في الرياض احنا عارفين صراحه
الاقتصاد عندنا ينمو بشكل كبير جدا
وبالتالي كبير على الرياض يعني الشركات
ايضا حتى تعديل
وهذا كله دفع الحقيقه ننتقل الى الرياض
قبل 202 الفيدرالي الامريكي لغز اخر في
التضخم يعني كلما رفع نسبه الفائده يا
دكتور وتوقعنا انه نسبه التضخم حتنخفض او
دعني اقول يعني المستويات التي يستهدفها
للانخفاض لا تتحقق فبالتالي هل نحن بصدد
زياده اخرى من قبل الفيدرالي الامريكي ام
ان الخطوات التي اخذها في داره الفيدراليه
الامريكي في في في رفع نسب الفائده لم تكن
كافيه الحقيقه
من شهر مارس في عام 22 وبدا بمساله تشديد
في السياسات النقديه
ويحاول ان هو يعني يصل لاهدافه
الاستراتيجيه بانه يرفع التضخم في مستويات
في 2% صحيح ان التضخم انخفض من اكثر من 9%
يعني مع زياده الفيدرالي الامريكي
لمستويات الفائده اليوم حنا نتكلم على اخر
يعني احصائيه في التضخم كان 6.4 وكانت دون
المتوقع لانهم كانوا يتوقعوا انه يصل الى
سته فاصله اثنين
الواضح انه الفيدرالي الامريكي مستمر على
سياسته يعني اعتقد ممكن اعتقد انه في
الاجتماع القادم ان يكون هناك ايضا زياده
في يعني في اسعار الفائده
ربما هذا يكون الرفع الاخير او هم بالنسبه
الاخير بيحاولوا قدر المستطاع ان يرجعوا
بمستويات التضخم الى مستوياته الطبيعيه
فبالتالي ايضا الفيدرالي بيحاول انه هو
يعني يوازن ما بين النمو او خلينا نقول
الركود لا يدخل الاقتصاد الامريكي في
مراحل الركود وبين النسب الفائده اللي ما
في شك انه حيكون لها اثر كبير وبخصوصا على
الانشطه غير النفطيه بخصوص يا دكتور
بعض التصريحات دائما عن
التراجع المتوقع في في نسبه التضخم في
السعوديه في
2023ربما يمكن ابرز هذه التصريحات من وزير
كيف يمكن للتضخم في السعوديه ان يتراجع
اختصار الاجراءات اللي اتخذتها الحكومه من
وقت مبكر يعني جعلت مستويات التضخم حتى
وان شاهدنا انه ثلاثه فاصل اربعه لا يدعوا
القلق الحقيقه ثلاثه فاصل اربعه يعني انا
اعتقد مقارنه ولكن هو مقارنه بالمستويات
العالميه احنا اليوم امام يعني تضخم على
مستوى عالمي كبير جدا دول تجاوزت الخمسين
بالمئه
الاحداث الجيو السياسيه لها اثر ايضا
الاسعار الطاقه
الجائحه كورونا لم يتم التعافي منها في
العالم بشكل كامل كل هذه الامور الحقيقه
حينما نشاهد الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
السعوديه من تحديد سقف لاسعار الطاقه في
السعوديه كان لها اثر جدا ايجابيا اللي
قدمتها الحكومه يعني المتوقع انه خلال
الفتره القادمه ان المملكه هدف عندها
اساسي ان هي تراجع مستويات التضخم من
المستويات اللي احنا بنشاهدها اليوم وان
شاء الله نحن نحقق اهدافنا مع يعني خلينا
نقول في النصف الاول حتى في عام 23 ان شاء
الله مع انه العام التوقعات دائما غير
مبشره يعني فعلا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر كان معي هنا في الاستاد
الماليه والاستثمار بكليه الاقتصاد بجامعه
الامام الدكتور محمد مكان شكرا دكتور الله
يسلمك
مباشره الى مؤتمر صحفي لوزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجي
محتجون في اوكرانيا
والذين قاموا علينا الحرب ضد كل ما هو
روسي وطرد كل ما هو روسي من القرم
وقال انهم منذ هذه الاوقات كان
نعطوا يستعيده للحرب ضد روسيا للحرب
العجينه ولو تحدثنا عن
وكاله سبور وكان ادخالهم تم ادخالهم في
قائمه
علماء الاجانب الولايات المتحده قبل خمس
سنوات
من بدايه عمليه العسكريه الخاصه او هذا هو
من ان اعصر الحرب الهجينه
بنطاق واسع ضدنا
وقبل اسبوع اعلن صرح السيد باريل
امام الجماهير وعلى
التصرفات للوكاله حظر الوكل وصل الاعلام
الروسيه في اوروبا
هو من اجراءات على الحفاظ على حريه
التعبير
وانتم تعرفون جيدا ما تقوم بوكاله
ترون
انتهاكات لحريه التعبير في عملكم
وسيكون من المهم ان نسمع ذلك منكم اليوم
نرى من ذلك عدم التسامح
لاختلاف في الراي
اختلافري هو
جزء من سياسه الليبراليه
ومن وجهه النظره القانونيه
هذه
العلامه الروسيه هو انتهاك للالتزامات
التي تولتها العضو للغربيه في اطار منظمه
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا
وخاصه فيما يخص
وامكانيات للوصول المواطنين الى كل مصادر
المعلومات في اوروبا في خارج اوروبا
هو مبادرين
نكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر الصحفي او
الكلمه لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض دشنا امير
المنطقه منطقه الرياض مشروع ضاحيه الفرسان
كاكبر حي سكني بالرياض يتبع للشركه
الوطنيه للاسكان وذلك على مساحه 35 مليون
متر مربع هذا وياتي المشروع بعد توجيه ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
لزياده المعروض العقاري
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو رئيس
التنفيذي للوطنيه للاسكان محمد البطيخي
سيدي محمد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض نبارك لكم اولا اطلاق هذا
المشروع وخلينا نعرف اكثر عن اكبر
المشاريع او اكبر الاحياء السكنيه في
الرياض ضاحيه الفرسان ايش تفاصيلها اهلا
بكم اسعد الله مسائك بكل خير الحمد لله
اليوم نسعد بالتدشين ضاحيه الفرسان
ونتقدم بالشكر الجزيل لصاحب السمو الملكي
الامير فيصل بن بندر بن عبد العزيز على
حضوره وتشريفه وتدشينه هذه الضاحيه التي
تعد ليست الاكبر على مدينه الرياض بل
على مستوى المملكه
ضاحيه بمساحه 35 مليون متر مربع وتاتي
بدعم كبير من القياده ودعم وتوجيه مباشر
من سيدي الامير محمد بن سلمان في التخصيص
اراضي الاسكان اخرها طبعا ضاحيه خزام
واليوم ضاحيه الفرسان
اللي اليوم دشنها الحمد لله
طبعا الضاحي هذه مساحتها 35 مليون متر
مربع تحويل على خمسين الف وحده سكنيه بحول
الله بعد انتهاء كامل مراحلها تتسع ل 250
الف نسمه
بمجموع استثمارات يتجاوز 45 مليار ريال ان
شاء الله بالشراكه مع القطاع الخاص شركه
الوطنيه اليوم كمطور وطني ولاعب وطني كبير
في مجال التطوير العقاري
والخدمات المسانده للتطوير العقاري سواء
الخدمات تجاريه وترفيهيه اوسعيه او غيرها
فمجموعه الاستثمارات بتجاوز فيها 45 ونعمل
احنا كمطور وطني وممكن وطني في القطاع
العقاري
بدات اليوم الحمد لله اول مراحل واحنا
نستهدف تطوير يعني مجموعه مشاريع في
الرياض اليوم
ضاحت الفرسان
اللي حتى راعينا في تصميمها ليس فقط
التصميم الوحدات السكنيه بل اخذ كامل
معايير جوده الحياه والمرافق العامه
والخدمات مش بعيد جوده الحياه او مفهوم
حتى ايضا جوده الحياه بالنسبه للوطنيه
اللي ممكن يتنفذ وكيف تمكنوا اساسا
الشركاء اللي موجودين معكم من تعزيز هذه
الفكره مفهوم جوده الحياه في هذا الحي
وجود كل الخدمات واي احد يفكر انه يشتري
بهالمكان يعني مش المحفز اللي اللي يقدمه
طبعا معايير تبدا من تخطيط التخطيط الحضري
او التخطيط لهذه الاراضي والمساحات بحيث
انه تؤخذ في الاعتبار التوزيع المناطق
السكنيه وتوزيع المناطق الخدميه والتجاريه
بحيث انها تعطي مساحات اكبر المناطق
المفتوحه
والذات متعدد وايضا تقلل من حركه نقل
السيارات وتشجع على حركه المشعه والدراجات
تتنوع الخدمات بحيث انه تكون كان اللي
ساكن ساكن في وسط
مساحه اكبر كبير جدا عامه ومملوكه له حركه
المشاه ما تتعدى خمس الى سبع دقائق
للخدمات الرئيسيه مثلا مثل المسجد او
السوبر ماركت الصغير او الحديقه
ناخذ في الاعتبار انه ما تتعدى من خمس الى
سبع دقائق
للخدمات الاكبر من عشر دقائق الى ربع ساعه
هذه بالنسبه لحركه المشاه استخدام المناطق
الحدائق بشكل اكبر نستهدف مثلا زراعه نصف
مليون شجره في في ضاحه الفرسان مجموع
الحدائق تساعد على المشي بشكل كبير
الوحدات السكنيه وتوزيعها مناسب لكثير من
الاسر يعني تعيش في وسط مكان كبير تستخدم
مناطق عامه كثيره اللي ساكن تستخدمها
كانها انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر ما تبقى عندي
الكثير من الوقت يعطيك الف عافيه
انضمام علينا الوطني للاسكان السيد محمد
البطيء شكرا لك
اعلنت الهيئه العمل النقل في السعوديه عن
توقيع اكبر مشروع لنقل الركاب الحافلات
بين مدن السعوديه
وذلك من خلال شبكه نقل تمتد لاكثر من 200
مدينه ومحافظه كما من المتوقع ان يقدم
المشروع اكثر من سته ملايين راكب سنويا
عبر 76 مسارا
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو المتحدث
باسم الهيئه العملي النقل صالح زويتي
صلاحيه
من الرياض خلينا نعرف اولا تفاصيل هذه
المشروع المشروع النقل الاكبر في السعوديه
وبين مدنها ومناطقها حياك الله واشكركم
على التطرق لهالموضوع المهم وفعلا اليوم
يوم تاريخي في قطاع النقل بالحافلات بين
المدن في المملكه اليوم في تم توقيع ثلاث
عقود امتياز
لتقديم خدمات نقل نقل ركاب بالحافلات بين
المملكه مشروع ضخم يخدم اكثر من مدينه
ومحافظه يخدم اكثر من 6 مليون راكب سنوي
ايضا يقدم خدماته من خلال سته وسبعين مسار
بارجاء المملكه الواسعه هذا المشروع له
اليوم مرتبط باستراتيجيات متعدده سواء
مباشره استراتيجيه الوطنيه لنقل الخدمات
اللوجسيه ايضا استراتيجيه داعمه
استراتيجيه كثير من القطاعات
النقل الممكن لتحقيق مستهدفاتها وممكن
ايضا لتحقيق طموحاتها هذا اليوم تم توقيع
ثلاث عقود بعد 45 سنه كان هناك عقد امتياز
واحد لشركه واحده اليوم سوق مفتوحة لثلاث
شركات واذا سؤال مهم انه انه اليوم في
تقسيم اصلا اللي سوق نقل الركاب في
الحافلات ودخل تحالفات كبرى سواء كانت
محليه والعالميه احنا نبغى نعرف يعني عن
هذه التحالفات عن هذه العقود ايضا
وتوزيعها في المناطق اليوم من ضمن الدراسه
اللي كانت مثل هذا المشروع هو دراسه خطوط
الشبكه بحيث انه نضمن ربحيه هذا المشروع
والجدول الماليه منه بناء بدايه من
الدراسه السوق المحلي شركات العالميه ايضا
قطاع النقل في الشركات والمماثله في مختلف
دول العالم مرورا باطلاع على افضل
الممارسه الدوليه ثم دراسه العرض والطلب
هنا في السعوديه مراعاه الاستراتيجيات
المختلفه سواء استراتيجيات القطاعيه برامج
الرؤيه
بناء شبكه تتناسب مع العرض والطلب
وتقسيمها من حيث الخطوط الاكثر ربحيه
والخطوط الاقل ربحيه بحيث يكون في توازن
بين عقود الامتياز تم تقسيم المملكه لثلاث
مناطق امتياز كل منطقه لتحالف من هذه
التحالفات التحالف يضم شركه محليه وايضا
شريك شركه اجنبيه بحيث يكون هناك تبادل
الخبرات وايضا جذب لافضل التقنيات مثل
المفروض تبدا الشركه اليوم مع وزير نقل
شهد توقيع العقود واعلنوا ان شاء الله
خلال هذا العام سنرى هذه الرحلات تجوب
انحاء المملكه باذن الله بالتوفيق لكم ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك كان معي هنا في
الاستوديو المتحدث باسم الهيئه العامه
للنقل السيد صالح زويد شكرا لك
كشفت وزاره الحج والعمره عن وصول اعداد
المعتمرين القادمين والمغادرين الى نحو
خمسه ملايين معتمر في العام الجاري فيما
بلغ اجمالي المعتمرين الموجودين في
السعوديه حتى يوم امس اكثر من 500 الف
معتمر من جنسيات مختلفه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
السعوديه تعلن عن اكتشافات اثريه تعود
لعصور ما قبل الاسلام بمنطقه نجران
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت هيئه التراث
السعوديه عن اكتشاف عدد من النقوش
المسنديه الجنوبيه
وثلاثه خواتم وراس ثور من البرونز يعود
الى عصور ما قبل الاسلام وذلك ضمن اعمال
التنقيب في موقع الاخدود بمنطقه نجران كما
عثرتي التراث على فقاريه بمختلف الاحجام
والمقاسات بالاضافه ايضا الى اكتشاف اناء
من الخزف الذي يؤرخ الى القرن الثالث قبل
الميلاد
شكرا محمد العرب القدماء اطلقوا على السحب
الصيفيه السحب العكسيه لانها تاتي من جهه
الشرق الى الغرب التفاصيل في تقويم عقد
الزاحق
[موسيقى]
ينزل علينا المطر من السحاب والغمام
والمعصرات فالسحاب ماخوذه من سحب الشيء
فهي تسحب لنا الماء من مكان الى مكان اخر
بحبل الرياح والغمام ماخوذه من الغمه وهي
الغطاء فهي تغطي وجه السماء عنا والعامه
يسمون سقف المنزل بلغما واحيانا تحصر
الرياح اللواقه الغمامه في زاويه واحده
وتعصر ما في جوفها من ميافه تسمى المعصرات
ليت الغمام الذي عندي صواعقه يزيلهن الى
من عنده الدين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن باب العموم السحب تنقسم الى قسمين سحب
صيفيه وسحب شتويه الصيفيه هي السحب
العابره وعاده ما تكون في طبقات الجو
العليا والعامه يسمونها بالسحب العكسيه
لانها قادمه من جهه الشرق الى جهات الغرب
والسحب الشتويه وهي سحب الماطره وعاده ما
تكون في طبقات الجو المتوسطه والدنيا
اريقت واصحابي قعود بربوه لبرق تلالا في
تهامه
لامعوا
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوينها
اداره الكوارث التركيه تسجل اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف وثمانمائه منذ زلزال السادس من
فبراير
الفريق السعودي التطوعي يواصل نصب مئه
خيمه يوميا لمتضرر الزلزال في قهرمان مرعش
معدل التضخم يسجل ارتفاعا في السعوديه
خلال يناير الماضي والسكن والمواد
الغذائيه ضمن الاعلى ارتفاعا
هيئه نقل السعوديه توقع عقد لنقل الركاب
بالحافلات بين المدن من خلال شبكه تصل لي
200 مدينه
شكرا على كرمه نهايه الرابعه او دول
القاكم غدا الى اللقاء